et avec nous pour ce club Loïc Quentin
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nos
présidents de la Fédération nationale de
l'immobilier Michel Bisson bonjour merci
d'être là vous êtes mère de Lieusaint en
Seine-et-Marne vice-président de France
urbaine et Audrey nous a rejoint parce
que le débat de ce club est consacré à
la crise du logement on n'a jamais aussi
peu construit de logements dans notre
pays et avec l'inflation des taux
d'intérêt à la hausse beaucoup de
Français doivent renoncer à leurs rêves
d'être propriétaire les professionnels
du secteur tirent la sonnette d'alarme
et demande des mesures mais lesquelles
comment sortir de l'impasse ce sera le
débat du club à suivre dans quelques
instants d'abord on regarde ensemble
l'actualité dans nos régions
[Musique]
et l'information dans nos régions c'est
cette mobilisation qui avait lieu hier
en soutien au maire de Saint-Brévin en
Loire-Atlantique qui vous le savez à
démissionner après des menaces et
l'incendie partielle de son domicile
personnel pour en parler on est en
direct avec Johanna Roland bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous Johanna Roland
vous êtes la mère de Nantes chef-lieu de
la Loire-Atlantique première secrétaire
déléguée du Parti socialiste et
présidente de France urbaine c'est
l'Association des maires de grandes
villes et de métropoles on l'a vu hier
cette mobilisation de soutien au maire
de Saint-Brévin à l'appel de la gauche
et en l'absence des républicains en
l'absence de la majorité présidentielle
est-ce que finalement ça s'est
transformé en mobilisation partisane
cette margière
non je ne crois pas parce que les
organisations politiques ont fait
chacune leur choix mais il y avait sur
le terrain des élus de sensibilité
diverses qui à titre individuel à titre
personnel on considéré ensemble que
jamais jamais un élu de la République ne
devrait se retrouver obligé de choisir
entre son mandat d'élus son dévouement
pour la chose publique et la protection
de sa famille c'est ça ce qui nous a
rassemblé collectivement hier à
Saint-Brevin dans un contexte quand même
très particulier vous regrettez que ça
ne vous ai pas rassemblée plus largement
vous regrettez que ça finalement que des
parties de gauche même si vous le dites
il y avait d'autres personnes dans la
manifestation mais encore une fois les
autres parties dont nous vous ont pas
rejoint
je crois que face à des situations aussi
graves chacun prend ses responsabilités
nous avons pris les nôtres j'ai pris les
miennes et je salue les mers je le redis
moi je connais un certain nombre de mère
de la métropole chez moi à Nantes de
sensibilités
aussi présent donc je voudrais pas qu'on
passe sous silence leur mobilisation
parce que je crois que le moment est
vraiment à faire front parce que quand
ma mère est attaqué en réalité c'est
toute la République qui recule on est
quand même dans un contexte où il y a eu
une augmentation des violences de 32%
l'année dernière à l'égard des élus et
puis on est dans un contexte où il faut
le dire à Saint-Brévin le rôle
nauséabond joué par l'extrême droite et
quand même extrêmement préoccupant on a
des militants reconquêtes qui étaient
venus manifester jusque devant le perron
de la mairie on a une forme de machine
au harcèlement infernal qui s'est
déclenché on a des députés du
rassemblement national qui ne se sont
pas levés dans l'hémicycle comme un
hommage a été rendu à Yannick Morez on a
un maire qui accueillait sur son
territoire un projet qui était un projet
de l'État donc c'est de tout ça je crois
donc on a d'abord besoin de parler et
là-dessus vous avez entendu Annie Genval
je sais pas s'il a bien entendu il y a
quelques minutes ce qui était avec nous
et qui se disait inquiète des
conséquences pour les élus locaux de la
politique migratoire dans notre pays et
notamment de la volonté de répartir les
migrants est-ce que vous vous partagez
ces inquiétudes qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ça
d'abord moi je pense que le droit
d'asile en France c'est l'honneur de
notre pays c'est la grande Histoire de
la France je crois ensuite que on a eu
29 lois sur l'immigration depuis 40 ans
donc cette forme de surenchère
législative sur fond de fantasmes
d'instrumentalisation des peurs de
logique du soi-disant tsunami migratoire
je pense qu'il faut mettre un peu de
rationalité sur ces sujets on a besoin
de faire les choses mais de les faire
bien on a besoin de pragmatisme aussi je
salue Michel Bisson qui représente
France urbaine sur votre plateau comme
moi comme tous les maires et toute
sensibilité il pourra témoigner de
situations complètement absurde par
exemple où on a des gens sur nos
territoires qui sont ni régularisables
ni expulsables c'est ça la vérité
aujourd'hui de logique qui ne fonctionne
pas c'est aussi à ces questions là qu'il
faut répondre et puis pour les
socialistes on fera un certain nombre de
propositions j'en cite une il est urgent
de réformer le système dit de Dublin
tant qu'on n'aura pas avancé sur ce
sujet là aussi on ne réglera pas un
certain nombre de questions concrètes
qui sont indispensables qu'on se place
du point de vue de l'humanisme français
ou qu'on se place du point de vue de la
sérénité et de la tranquillité du pays
au-delà de la question de l'immigration
cette démission du maire de Saint-Brévin
a mis un peu plus en lumière la question
des violences envers les élus vous
l'avez dit plus 32% d'augmentation vous
êtes entretenu hier avec le maire suite
à sa démission le gouvernement a fait
des propositions en renforcement des
sanctions pénales impact sécurité des
référents gendarmerie est-ce que pour
vous ces propositions sont les bonnes
je crois que ça va dans le bon sens mais
c'est insuffisant il y a au moins deux
sujets qui ne sont aujourd'hui pas
traités le premier les moyens concrets
côté gendarmerie et police nationale
pour accueillir les plaintes les
démarches des maires hier encore à
Saint-Brévin j'ai entendu le témoignage
de nombreuses élus qui m'ont raconté
concrètement voilà j'ai été menacé j'ai
été attaqué je me suis rendue à la
gendarmerie on m'a dit on n'est pas
forcément équipé on n'a pas forcément
les moyens de donner suite donc ça c'est
un premier sujet ensuite il reste des
questions réglementaires on sait que les
choses démarre malheureusement beaucoup
sur les réseaux sociaux qui sont une
forme de défouloir avec la lâcheté de
celles et ceux qui écrivent cachés
derrière un écran de smartphone
d'ordinateur aujourd'hui le délai de
prescription sur les réseaux sociaux il
est 3 mois c'est absolument insuffisant
donc il y a une première étape qui a été
franchie France urbaine et la MF
ensemble on fait des propositions je
crois vraiment qu'il faut aller plus
loin un dernier mot Johanna Roland hier
en conseil des ministres en parlant de
la violence à envers les élus mais pas
seulement vers les forces de l'ordre
envers le personnel soignant Emmanuel
Macron a parlé d'un processus de
décibilisation vous partagez ces mots
moi d'abord vous avez bien vu comment le
débat sémantique à partir de cette prise
de parole s'ouvre qu'elle ambiguïté dans
ce mot quelle référence à quoi ça
renvoie quel rhétorique mais au-delà de
ça tu crois moi surtout que le pays il a
pas besoin d'une surenchère verbale
permanente inventée en permanence par le
Président de la République le pays il a
besoin de quoi il a besoin de moyens
concrets pour les soignants de moyens
concrets pour la psychiatrie de moyens
concrets pour la police et la
gendarmerie je crois moi que l'heure est
aux actes aux actions et pas à une forme
de diversion sémantique pour le moins
contestable sur le plan des idées et du
fond merci Johanna Roland merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous je le rappelle
vous êtes mère de nom de présidente de
France urbaine première secrétaire
déléguée du Parti socialiste merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité pour
parler de cette actualité on va passer
au débat de ce club on va parler de la
crise du logement autour de cette
question le rêve français d'être
propriétaire est-il encore accessible
aujourd'hui d'abord Loïc Quentin avec
vous quelles sont les facteur de cette
crise du logement est-ce que cette crise
du logement est inédite aujourd'hui dans
notre pays il y a longtemps que je
n'avais pas être crise immobilière
importante c'est remontent aux années 90
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
atterrissage sur eux il faut regarder 30
années en arrière dans le rétroviseur
sur peut-être des mesures ou des
anticipations une prospective que n'ont
pas conduit les politiques publiques et
afin d'anticiper la période que l'on vit
voilà on a connu une période de
décélération des taux d'intérêts qui ont
accompagné une dynamique des marchés de
l'immobilier depuis 1998 moments où les
taux ont continué à baisser qui ont
alimenté une hausse des prix et
soudainement des confronté une inflation
contre laquelle l'ABC a lutte de toutes
ses forces et notamment pour réduire et
en augmentant les taux malheureusement
c'est tôt et cette hausse vient frapper
la capacité d'emprunt des ménages
français elle est brutale elle est
violente elle attaque le marché du neuf
et avant effectivement d'impacter le
marché de la transaction et le parcours
résidentiel des Français donc il y a
deux effets il y a une baisse de pouvoir
d'achat des acheteurs et deux il y a un
problème dans la construction de
logement oui puis dans les politiques
aussi publiques la façon de conduire
notamment l'aménagement du territoire la
ville avoir un véritable ministère du
Logement dédié que nous n'avons plus
l'aménagement du territoire fait plus
partie de nos objectifs de notre vision
stratégique qu'il faut penser la
politique du logement différemment et je
l'ai maintes fois dit la politique du
logement c'est pas qu'une ligne
budgétaire dans la loi de finances c'est
autre chose c'est un autre regard et ce
que les professionnels appellent est-ce
que vous êtes vice-président de France
urbaine Michel Bisson est-ce que tout le
territoire connait une crise du logement
ou est-ce qu'il y a des inégalités
territoriales là-dessus
moi je suis très heureux d'évoquer ce
sujet et de parler après Johanna Roland
ma présidente préférée de François
urbaine je pense qu'il y a une il y a
les données qui ont été très bien
expliquées puis je pense qu'il y a une
un élément supplémentaire maintenant qui
vient sur ajouter à tout cela et qui
nous oblige à changer de paradigme ce
cet élément supplémentaire c'est le
réchauffement climatique et la
nécessaire transition écologique et en
l'occurrence elle se concrétise sur ce
sujet là tout particulièrement par le
zéro artificialisation nette et je crois
que c'est une erreur que d'opposer la
production de logements avec le 0
artificialisation net ça nous oblige
tout simplement à regarder les choses
autrement à changer à changer à changer
de paradigme mais ce changement de
paradigme nous oblige aussi à avoir un
regard plus précis sur l'existant voilà
parce qu'on parle beaucoup de production
bien sûr qu'il y a une attente en
matière de construction de logements il
y a énormément de foyers qui sont en
attente qui vivent dans des conditions
qui sont des conditions absolument pas
tolérables et en même temps
je pense que la seule réponse ne peut
pas être la production elle doit être
aussi la production certes mais un
regard un regard sur sur l'existant à
travers donc la rénovation donc la
rénovation la rénovation mais aussi un
regard peut-être plus précis et
certaines peut-être taxation sur les
logements dit touristique qui
fleurissent aujourd'hui dans un certain
nombre de grosses agglomérations bien
évidemment mais aussi le fait que des
immeubles de tertiaires peuvent être
reconvertis en logement à leur je dirais
du poscovide et de l'accélération de
comment dirais-je du télétravail il y a
là des des immeubles tertiaires donc qui
se désertifient et qui pourrait être
convertis et puis il y a aussi tous ces
logements aujourd'hui qui ne sont pas
loués qui sont en attente parce que la
rénovation thermique est une obligation
aujourd'hui donc on voit bien que c'est
trois facteurs là sont déjà de nature à
débloquer un certain nombre de logements
qui permettraient de répondre compatible
et écologie on sait que le bâtiment
c'est un fort émetteur de gaz à effet de
serre est-ce que écologie et
construction de logements c'est encore
compatible ça doit l'être je crois que
et ça doit l'être c'est pour ça que le
changement de paradigme est important
que la rénovation thermique doit être
une priorité aujourd'hui on a des
objectifs 2050 il y a des logements qui
sont plus loin avec la rénovation
thermique est-ce que ça va aggraver
encore la crise du logement sur la
rénovation thermique c'est pour ça qu'il
doit y avoir une accélération de la
rénovation thermique et un
accompagnement de la rénovation
thermique qui est aussi très bénéfique
en termes d'emploi très bénéfique en
termes d'emploi voilà le le monde de la
construction les mondes de promoteurs
évidemment nous renvoient toute la
question de l'emploi qu'on peut
évidemment comprendre la question
économique la question de l'emploi on y
a évidemment sensible je pense qu'une
des réponses c'est voilà de faire un pas
de côté et d'être volontariste sur la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
la compatibilité entre écologie
finalement et construction de logements
est-ce qu'il faut pas se résoudre à
construire aujourd'hui construire mieux
mais construire moi nous avons besoin
dans tous les cas de ce chiffre un
compressible de 350 000 logements par an
parce que si nous ne l'assurons pas nous
sommes effectivement en sous-offre et
aujourd'hui il y a une grasse crise dans
la crise construction neuf parce que les
logements sont commercialisent plus sur
la rénovation énergétique et bien
évidemment que dans tous les cas ça fait
partie de l'ambition et je dirais tous
l'écosystème de l'immobilier il faut et
nous avons cet objectif de décarbonation
pour 2050 simplement comment y arriver
aujourd'hui les signaux qui sont envoyés
par la loi climat résilience frappant à
des sens notamment des logements au 1er
janvier 2025 nous empêche aujourd'hui de
répondre à cette commande donc on va
avoir une attrition du parc locatif je
pense spécifiquement à Paris 40% de
l'offre locative est classée en F et G
et que va-t-il se passer et puis il y a
des immeubles qu'on ne peut pas
notamment remonter la classe énergétique
on peut plus
2028 il y a des immeubles bosmaniens
qu'on ne peut pas isoler par l'extérieur
il va falloir le faire par l'intérieur
donc il y a des complications les
immeubles à colombages on peut pas le
faire maintenant maintenant sur la
rénovation du parc moi je voudrais quand
même apporter une précision on parle de
logements vacants les logements vacants
sont pas là où on le situer les
logements vacance sont pas dans les
grandes villes les logements vacances
sont dans la diagonale vide du vide
c'est un million de logements de plus en
15 ans que nous avons eu sur ce parc
c'est un million de logements sont
partent d'une ores au sud-ouest c'est à
dire dans des territoires désertés et on
leur demande d'être rénové avec un coup
de rénovation qui est le même dans une
grande ville avec une prime rénove qui
est au même niveau et qui n'est pas
compatible on peut pas rénover et avoir
700 euros de rénovation au mètre carré
quand on a un logement qui en vaut 12
100 au mètre carré quand certaines
villes affichent 10000 euros en moyenne
on va on a parlé d'écologie on va parler
aussi des difficultés des Français
accéder à la propriété pour des
questions de prix le rêve de devenir
propriétaire est-il accessible Mathias
arès est allé rencontrer ces signaux
bientôt 28 ans il aimerait devenir
propriétaire problème avec la hausse des
taux d'intérêt sa capacité d'emprunt
baisse un véritable problème que vive
beaucoup d'inspirant la propriété
regarde et trop cher pour ce que j'ai
tout seul
appartement Rillieux-la-Pape à 117000
euros c'est dans mon budget avec une
bonne surface mais c'est trop
trop excentré de là où je travaille
depuis un an il cherche la perle rare
c'est vraiment très compliqué parce que
soit les appartements que je cherche et
qui me plaisent et qui ont un prix
abordable soit en viager ou en location
actuelle et pas disponible avant deux
trois ans soit l'appartement c'est un
tout petit studio dans lequel en fait on
peut même pas en fait on a justement
mètre carré et c'est une chambre
d'étudiant on passe qui donc du coup
c'est quand on a envie de d'avoir de
l'esp pour soi une chambre d'étudiant
c'est pas le meilleur
technicien informatique le jeune actif
est en CDI et gagne 1700 euros net par
mois de quoi constituer une mise de
départ mon premier rapport est entre
35000 et 40.000 euros ça me permet de
voir des appartements qui sont au total
sans les frais de notaire et sans les
autres charges à environ 130 135000
euros mais ces derniers mois la donne a
changé d'un côté les prix baisses de
l'autre les taux d'intérêt montant
flèche je me retrouve à avoir des
appartements peut-être encore plus petit
qu'avant et tout en payant la même chose
il y a une perte de il y a une perte au
niveau de ma compétence à pouvoir
acheter quelque chose aujourd'hui sa
banque est en mesure de lui prêter
120.000 euros mais contrairement à il y
a encore quelques mois cécilio est plus
vigilant j'ai pas envie de me lancer
comme ça à la valide parce que c'est
quand même un endroit où je risque d'y
vivre plus de 10 ans
et
je veux je me vois pas acheter un
appartement pour le revendre dans deux
ans un contexte qui pousse le potentiel
acheteur vers une forme de lassitude
pour l'instant ça me démotive pas mal ça
me despotait énormément parce que
j'aimerais bien pouvoir avoir mon petit
chez moi me dire que je rentre du boulot
je suis tranquille personne va me
déranger et tout ça finalement bah c'est
toujours retardé d'avoir un peu de
tranquillité malheureusement ce marasme
risque de se poursuivre une bonne partie
de 2023 puisque les taux devraient
continuer de grimper au moins jusqu'à
l'été
et c'est plus trois aujourd'hui
donc on aura réduit la capacité
d'empreinte 25% mais ça illustre bien
notamment que la politique du logement
doit aussi s'orienter ça a toujours été
finalement ce qui a valorisé nos
politiques prises précédentes
d'accompagner les primorants or
aujourd'hui nous avons pas plus que de
mesure pour les primes excédents on a
mis en place des mesures pour le 9 pour
l'investisseur qui est déjà propriétaire
de son logement qui lui à côté n'a pas
le droit du même traitement est-ce que
il vaut mieux pas être accéder à la
propriété que donner des avantages un
propriétaire déjà propriétaire c'est une
question que je pose depuis longtemps et
je pense qui est tout à fait censé et
surtout dans ce cadre-là il faut
favoriser l'accession la propriété je
pense que l'avenir et l'horizon des
Français c'est au moment de la retraite
d'avoir un toit assez fondamental je
pense c'est une perspective définitive
et qu'il faut en créer dans les
politiques publiques et ça nous avons
oublié cette cet aspect là notamment
dans la politique du logement il faut la
restaurer absolument ça a été oublié cet
aspect là peut-être tout gouvernement
confondu parce que le problème ne date
pas d'hier non plus il y a une priorité
à donner au primo-accédant à l'évidence
ensuite il y a effectivement du du
capital qui est inscrit et du coup les
choses sont un peu plus simples en
deuxième ou troisième acquisition je
pense que les besoins doivent précéder
l'offre voilà les besoins doivent
précéder l'offre ça nécessite alors
c'est pas une solution court terme enfin
quand même d'avoir une politique
d'aménagement du territoire dans ce pays
qui n'existe plus et je crois qu'à
l'heure de la réindustrialisation du
pays même si tout cela prendra du temps
il y a place pour faire en sorte que les
villes moyennes redeviennent beaucoup
plus attractives et ainsi déconcentre et
redonne de la capacité à construire là
où il y a guérir une qualité de vie même
si dans les métropoles bien évidemment
il y a aussi de la qualité de vie
ensuite je pense qu'il y a tout un
travail à faire l'aménagement du
territoire donc des en
gorger activité pour équilibrer quelque
part le prix du logement sur le
territoire
c'est-à-dire cela ne peut se faire que
s'il y a en même temps une politique
d'emploi et de services publics qui
accompagnent évidemment le logement donc
c'est pas pour demain donc c'est pas
pour demain pour demain il y a les les
capacités de construction des différents
promoteurs sur lequel il y a de
l'industrialisation à mener de manière à
baisser les coûts voilà
à la fois pour les raisons écologiques
mais aussi pour ne pas mettre de côté
par exemple les nuisances sonores
ensuite je pense qu'il y a des
dispositifs à imaginer pour dissocier la
construction du foncier parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui flambe évidemment
dans beaucoup de métropoles n'ont
beaucoup de de communes c'est plus le
foncier que les coûts de construction et
là il y a des dispositifs qui permettent
de dissocier de ne vendre que le bâti
d'avoir des des beaux à long terme sur
sur le foncier pour ne prendre que cet
exemple là il peut y avoir aussi des
dispositifs législatifs réglementaires
qui taxent de manière assez forte
évidemment le foncier pour éviter pour
éviter les plus-values je pense qu'il y
a là un sujet nouveau notamment à
l'heure d'usane du Zéro
artificialisation nette dont on doit
dont on doit dont on doit s'emparer et
ensuite il y a les solutions locales
c'est-à-dire je pense qu'aujourd'hui
sans parler de décentralisation parce
que sur ce sujet là le les possibilités
offertes par la différenciation nous
permet au niveau des territoires d'agir
mais il y a des leviers à donner pour
aller au bout de cette politique de
l'emploi de manière à ce que les
territoires soient encore un peu plus
des autorités organisatrices en matière
d'habitat mais aussi de transition
écologique et par exemple reprendre les
l'ensemble de ma prime rénov pour être
en capacité à l'échelle territoriale de
les porter dans une logique beaucoup
plus large qui permet de de mutualiser
l'ensemble des offres mais aussi d'avoir
un regard tout particulier sur la
précarité que peuvent vivre un certain
nombre de foyers et donc mobiliser des
aides toute particulière bref faire de
la dentelle et là il n'y a que les
territoires qui peuvent le faire
Loïc on se souvient d'une période pas si
l'antenne où les logements se vendaient
comme des petits pains restés très peu
longtemps sur le marché est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est encore le cas quand
on va être propriétaire aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il faut se dépêcher ou est-ce
qu'il y a plus de logements qui restent
sur les bras que de logement qui sont
pris d'assaut aujourd'hui il y a un
lentissement des transactions on a
terminé un million 100000 ventes dans
l'ancien en 2022 on a prévu un
atterrissage entre 900 950000 cette
année c'est à dire la compression des
volumes et qui s'accompagne aussi qui
précède toujours la baisse des prix et
la baisse des prix est enclenchée je
dirais que ça c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle pour lui c'est une bonne
nouvelle mais vous savez après c'est
ouais c'est une c'est un repère vous
savez entre acheter plus cher avec des
taux d'intérêt moins cher et acheter
moins cher plus cher le montant du
remboursement pour l'acquéreur
exactement la même chose après c'est une
question l'investissement c'est du long
terme il faut savoir où on va mais c'est
toujours le moment d'acheter la
problématique elle est elle est surtout
sur notamment les mesures d'urgence à
apporter sur ce secteur parce que on
arrive sur un marché qui est bloqué
quand on n'accepte pas la propriété et
bien on reste le locataire c'est le cas
de cette prime acc et qu'est-ce qui se
passe quand on reste locataire on libère
pas un logement pour d'autres qui
arrivent sur le marché un jeune cadre
qui vient qui sort de l'école qui est
muté ou qui arrive un ménage muté un
étudiant et on va gripper ce marché et
en plus le marché il est grippé parce
que il y a un retrait de l'offre
locative lié effectivement à l'indécence
énergétique dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure donc on a un blocage alors il
faut véritablement il faut donner de
l'oxygène il faut donner de la
visibilité de la lisibilité à ce marché
sur l'accession à la propriété la FNA
m'a fait des propositions simples nous
sommes parfaitement citoyens nous sommes
conscients que les recettes de l'État
sont exemples on a proposé dans un
contexte de hausse des prix afin de
prévenir une hausse et qui se poursuit
notamment de permettre la
transférabilité ou la portabilité des
prêts c'est-à-dire que vous avez
emprunté 1% vous êtes muté sur un autre
territoire vous devez acheter et
confronté à des taux de 3,80 et bien
vous pouvez transférer ce prêt sur un
autre acquisition ou éventuellement si
vous voulez pas en disposer vous pouvez
effectivement
la transférer à un autre acquéreur et
je pense que c'est une mesure qui est
simple qui ne coûte rien c'est une
question de courage politique je l'ai
proposé plusieurs fois aux banques
français j'attends des réponses et qui
est-ce que les banques est-ce que les
banques elles ont aussi avant la jouer
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui elles sont pas
contenu du de l'état du marché est-ce
qu'elles sont pas trop exigeantes en
demande dans trop d'app
qui exige qui les cantonnent notamment à
25 ans d'endettement 35% de 25 ans dans
dans le train et 35% dans des formes
maximum je pense qu'on peut libérer un
peu moi je ne suis pas pour augmenter le
ratio d'endettement des mèches français
les ménages français sont assez endettés
avec l'immobilier on peut augmenter la
durée de 25 à 27 ans comme on l'a fait
dans le débat sur la retraite deux ans
de plus pourquoi pas et mais surtout
c'est laisser au banquier qui est
capital emprunteur comment voulez-vous
être cadré quand vous avez un jeune
cadre qui est un contrat de travail il
est à 3000 euros on lui prévoit la
troisième année à 4000 euros est-ce que
le banquier n'est pas capable de
finalement d'apprécier son risque et de
prêter un jeune ménage voilà on est
tributaire de normes et qui ont encore
une fois bloque aussi un marché au
derrière la commission des affaires
économiques du Sénat auditionnelle le
président d'Action Logement dans un
contexte de crise du logement dont on
parle Bruno arcadiepan a lancé un cri du
cœur il craint une bombe sociale oui
avec une norme qui ne va pas arranger
les choses là non plus alors en quelques
mots d'abord Action Logement c'est un
organisme qui a 70 ans qui est codirigé
par le patronat et les syndicats et qui
est financé par une contribution sur les
entreprises son but c'est créer des
logements sociaux pour favoriser la
mobilité et des logements sociaux
actions logements ancré énormément 50000
par an un million 100000 depuis son
origine c'est le premier créateur de
logements sociaux à Mayotte par exemple
Oriane le problème c'est que tout
pourrait s'arrêter à cause d'un point
technique l'été dernier Lindsay a classé
Action Logement Action Logement service
pardon la branche qui collecte l'argent
en administration publique c'est un
classement technique pour tous les
organismes qui s'apparentent à une
organisation centrale sauf que ce point
technique fait entrer les dépenses
d'Action Logement dans les comptes
publics l'organisme ne pourra plus
s'endetter que sur une année alors je
vous apprends rien dans le logement sans
d'été sur une année ça permet de pas
faire grand chose vous l'imaginez donc
le président a lancé un cri du cœur hier
devant les sénateurs
on peut rien faire dans l'immobilier
avec une capacité d'emprunt à un an
quand on a plus les moyens de ma matin
de soutenir la mobilité
qu'allons-nous dire au chef d'entreprise
mais également aux salariés qui veulent
déménager ou prendre un emploi un peu
plus loin un salarié sur deux
aujourd'hui on mobilité refuse un emploi
s'il a pas de logement donc comment
allons-nous faire
parce que problème de logement ça crée
des risques pour l'emploi et pour la
réindustrialisation qu'Emmanuel Macron
appelle de ses vœux alors pour l'instant
le décret n'a pas encore été signé il
est peut-être encore temps en tout cas
Bruno
arcadiepan pardon a eu l'oreille des
sénateurs hier et puis je terminerai par
un chiffre que j'ai appris hier qui est
très révélateur sur le logement social
en 2017 il y avait un million 400 000
Français sur liste d'attentes
aujourd'hui ils sont 2 millions 400 000
ouais c'est énorme c'est une social à
venir Loïc Quentin premièrement
social rebondir sur ce qu'a dit Bruno
arcadiepel il a raison enfin c'est
Action Logement est un acteur de
référence du logement social en France
qui est financé par le 1% logement des
salariés français et on lui met des
bâtons dans les roues avec des normes
administratives qui vont bloquer
notamment cette production de logements
c'est impensable d'entendre ça c'est je
ne comprends pas cette vision
stratégique qui est une pure vision
technocratique quoi il faut avoir une
vision pragmatique notamment dans
l'accompagnement du parcours résidentiel
des Français et c'est le support même de
la mobilité économique et de la vie de
nos territoires et si on le bloque et
bien c'est encore un ingrédient de plus
je crois que voilà c'est le parfait
reflet reflète de l'absence de
prospective et de vision globale de ce
que doit être une politique du logement
mais à tous les niveaux que ce soit pour
le parc social le parc privé le parc
d'accession l'investissement tous ces
éléments sont indispensables à
l'écosystème et à l'équilibre de nos
marchés
que l'on pratique
de logement le pire je ne sais pas oui
en tout cas il y a un véritable sujet
mais je pense que tout cela traduit d'un
problème de méthode c'est à dire chacun
on fonctionne comme on fonctionnait
préalablement chacun dans son couloir
avec ses propres objectifs et à
l'arrivée on se rend compte que il y a
des décisions qui sont parfaitement
contre-productives par rapport à
l'objectif recherché donc il y a
vraiment une question de méthode et je
pense qu'il faut mettre autour de la
table l'ensemble des parties prenantes
la FNAME bien sûr Action Logement bien
sûr les bailleurs sociaux bien sûr
Conseil national de la rénovation sur le
logement ça a
servi à une consultation il devait y
avoir une grande masse militaire
mais vous en attendez rien non je ne
pense pas qu'on aura de grandes
propositions réformatrices à la hauteur
des enjeux que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
en tous les cas les propositions
un dernier mot peut-être là-dessus vous
dites lui Quentin que le pire est à
venir vous allez nous dire pourquoi mais
vous demandez notamment des moyens on
sait que l'État cherche à faire des
économies dans les dépenses et Gabriel
Atta le ministre des comptes publics a
déjà prévenu que le logement serait
particulièrement concernés par la baisse
des dépenses publiques alors si le
logement est à nouveau contributif
effectivement pour pouvoir gérer les
politiques publiques ou d'autres enjeux
je crois qu'il faut à mon avis
déterminer et préciser que le logement
doit être prioritaire aujourd'hui et
demain la construction neuve je ne suis
pas un soutien forcé de la construction
nous avons besoin de logements neuf pour
alimenter le marché ce secteur est en
difficulté il faut trouver des mesures
adaptées il faut trouver aussi des
mesures d'accompagnement sur le marché
de l'existant et surtout pas rompre
cette mobilité résidentielle et et le
parcours des Français ce serait
catastrophique je crois qu'il faut mieux
préférer dans un premier temps la fin de
mois plutôt que la fin du monde hein
donc faut se battre effectivement avec
un objectif et je crois que peut-être
être court termiste mais il faut savoir
moi je suis quand même révolté on frappe
distance un appartement que j'ai plus
sur notre 300000 SDF dans la rue alors
un moment il faut être réaliste quoi il
faut avoir un peu de bon sens dans cette
vision et se débarrasser de certains
dogmes
je pense qu'on peut concilier la fin du
monde et la fin du mois
je mets mes je pense que priorité doit
être donné au primo-accédant en terme
méthodologique il est important de
mettre tout le monde autour de la table
il est important de s'appuyer sur les
territoires parce que les territoires
ont des clés en matière foncière en
matière de en matière de régulation qui
qui sont absolument utiles aujourd'hui
dans la période que nous vivons oui moi
une simple mesure oui par exemple le
Pinel vous savez que nous l'entend le
nourrit la construction neuve ce Pinel
donc bénéficie certains investisseurs
locatifs aujourd'hui le Pinel est en
panne parce que il est moins intéressant
et d'autre part les taux de rendement
dégagés sur l'investissement sont
inférieurs autour d'intérêt donc il y a
plus d'investisseurs il s'intéresse à ce
produit moi j'ai on a fait une
proposition très simple c'est inscrit
dans le loi de finance il y a un budget
il y a une dotation budgétaire
permettant de faire profiter cette
réduction d'impôts à des primo excédents
à la propriété et on a effectivement je
ne demande pas à recharger la dette de
la France je dis simplement qu'il y a
une dotation soyons pragmatique et dont
ceux qui ont besoin de cette aide et en
particulier les primor excédents dans
l'instant ça viendra au secours du neuf
c'est une proposition pragmatique et
nous sommes économes et on a entendu vos
propositions et on espère qu'elles
seront entendues le 5 juin puisque c'est
ce jour-là Coralie le Conseil national
de la rénovation consacrée au logement
merci messieurs d'avoir été avec nous si
vous voulez bien rester quelques
instants on va regarder ce qu'elle a une
de nos quotidiens régionaux
[Musique]
et Audrey au quotidien reviennent ce
matin sur le décès de l'icône du rock
Tina Turner oui malgré l'annonce tard
hier soir de son décès certains de nos
quotidiens ont eu le temps de
bouleverser leur une avant l'envoi au
rotatif c'est le cas de la Marseillaise
et de la Provence qui rendent hommage à
celle qui était simply the best Royal je
vous laisserai chanter peut-être à la
fin de l'émission une carrière commencée
dans les années 50 des dizaines de tubes
oui 8 gremis le rock perd sa reine Tina
Turner c'est d'abord une rencontre avec
son premier mari à hic Turner qui l'a
rebapté Stina parce qu'elle s'appelait
Anna mais c'est aussi un mari tyrannique
et violent dont elle va réussir à
s'échapper avant d'avoir la carrière
qu'on lui connaît dans un petit encart
que vous voyez sur le côté de la Une de
Sud-Ouest le quotidien rappelle aussi
que Tina Turner a été la première femme
et la première artiste noire à faire la
couverture du célèbre magazine Rolling
Stones on va pas chanter tout de suite
l'actualité triste c'est aussi l'hommage
qui sera rendu qui est rendu ce matin à
Roubaix aux trois policiers tués ce
weekend dans le Nord oui dans une
collision frontale avec un chauff qui
conduisait sous l'empire de l'alcool et
de stupéfiant La Voix du Nord revient
sur l'hommage national rendu aujourd'hui
Emmanuel Macron sera présent pour rendre
hommage à Manon Paul et Steven il
recevront la Légion d'honneur et la
médaille du courage à titre postumorial
tout autre sujet c'est la montagne qui
s'intéresse au lithium et l'un des
projets les plus ambitions ambitieux de
l'Europe la mine de lithium des
chassières c'est un petit village dans
l'Allier qui pourrait permettre de
produire des batteries pour l'équivalent
tenez-vous bien de 700000 véhicules
électriques par an pendant plus de 25
ans nous explique le quotidien alors
évidemment vous l'imaginez le produit le
projet pardon réjouit autant qu'il
inquiète réjouit pour le nombre
d'emplois inquiètent pour les craintes
environnementales et puis je termine par
cette incroyable prouesse en une du
Dauphiné Libéré un homme paraplégique à
pu remarcher naturellement grâce à la
pensée grâce aussi à des chercheurs
grenoblois l'homme a désormais deux
implants sans fil dans le cerveau
l'autre dans la moelle épinière le
cerveau envoie l'intention qui arrive
dans un ordinateur qui le déconnecte et
qui envoie l'information à la moelle
épinière qui active les muscles c'est
phénoménal et je vous laisserai
découvrir le détail de cette prouesse
dans le Dauphiné Libéré et bravo
Grenoble
puisque c'est un peu votre vie l'autre
de l'étape je pouvais pas m'en empêcher
merci beaucoup merci Audrey pour cette
vie de presse merci Michel buisson
d'avoir été avec nous merci Loïc Quentin
d'être venu sur ce plateau merci à tous
de nous avoir suivi pour voir ou revoir
cette émission c'est sur notre nouvelle
plateforme public sénat.fr 18h vous avez
rendez-vous avec Thomas public et nous
on se retrouve demain très bonne journée
[Musique]